así es Pues un partido absolutamente
increíble el que ha realizado la
Selección Argentina para llevar
finalmente a esa tan anhelada final lo
hizo ante Croacia con tres goles por
acero en cinco minutos marcó los dos
primeros goles en la primer tiempo
gracias a un penalti de Leo Messi
cobrado perfectamente ante un Arquero
como oliva luego vendría también gola de
Julián Álvarez en una increíble jugada
colectiva unos tres pases muy bien desde
a profundidad para que Álvarez pudiera
marcar ese segundo gol de la Selección
Argentina y pues muy muy buena respuesta
por parte de la albiceleste a la presión
croata especialmente en los primeros
momentos del segundo tiempo donde
salieron a buscar el partido salieron a
buscar el empate y a pesar de que venían
a azorar a uno a dos los argentinos en
todo caso salieron esta vez con esta
mentalidad de defender el resultado
distinto a lo que habíamos visto ante
Países Bajos un partido más bien
bastante limpio sin
ninguno de estas cosas y luego pues
vendría ese tercer gol que quizás es un
gran golazo por parte de de Julián
Álvarez pero con un pase increíble de
Lionel Messi quien pues hace en el área
cosas completamente magistrales se
voltea y saca aguardió el que es uno de
los mejores defensas de este mundial
para ese tercer gol y de esta manera
pues la albiceleste pasa entonces a esta
final y Leo me sigue con ese gol ya se
convierte en el máximo goleador
histórico de la Selección Argentina